among a sea of well-wishers a group who
want to see an end to the monarchy
the UK's leading Republican movement
bearing banners saying not my king their
ambition to abolish the monarchy
peacefully and move to a parliamentary
Republic
and in part because it's insane that
we're spending all this money on a
parade when there are homeless people
sleeping in front of Westminster Abbey
um you know the whole idea of a
hereditary monarchy is ridiculous
there's no magic blood in this world
like the 67 million people on these
islands should be able to choose their
own head of state campaigners hoped
between one and two thousand people
would Boo the king as he passed but only
a few hundred are here before the
demonstration even got underway police
arrested six organizers and seized a
truck full of placards so far there's no
indication that protests were anything
but peaceful the whole point of today
was visibility of just to show that when
they came turned around but they
wouldn't see just Rose and Rose adoring
playlists and to show the world that
we're not a nation morning is but police
say they were held on suspicion of
breaching the peace in conspiracy to
cause public nuisance there would have
been intelligence active intelligence to
say that they intend to disrupt whether
they're carrying glue whether they want
to lock themselves to a national
infrastructure or jump in front of the
procession now if they did that that
would just hold everything back and it
would be a national embarrassment police
warned of new powers brought in to deal
with demonstrations including stopping
and searching people they suspect want
to cause disruption by protesting
the question is whether they overstretch
these new powers with these arrests
in a statement Human Rights Watch said
this is something you would expect to
see in Moscow not London peaceful
protests allowed individuals to hold
those in power to account something the
UK government seems increasingly averse
to though that
compared to those who've come out to
welcome the new king but polls do show
the popularity of the Royals has
dwindled from 75 a few years ago to 52
in the most recent poll what many find
hard to stomach is that this ceremony
will cost the taxpayer 80 million
dollars at a time when many are
struggling to pay their bills Charlie
Angela Al Jazeera London